hello everyone and welcome to a really
exciting game from the second round of
the super united rapid and blitz
tournament currently uh being played in
croatia it is
versus alireza
uh the world chess championship
challenger versus the the the prince
that was promised and uh
for those of you who haven't seen my
previous video or who have not been
following what's happening in the world
uh magnus will definitely not be
defending his title against yanni
pomnicci next year and the match will be
organized as yani palmishi versus being
lyran uh unless something changes who
knows maybe nepo will say all right but
now i don't want to play anyone except
magnus i mean even that it's possible
but chances are it will be nipple versus
being if you guys haven't seen it just
check the previous video it will be the
first link in the description below uh
but here we have a very exciting game
and apple has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 i know you guys were
probably hoping uh that
we're going to show the the game from
round one where magnus played against
nipple uh but the game was an absolute
snoozefest so i decided to skip that one
and uh this is one that i'm starting
with so e4 uh we have e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and the bishop the c4
alireza goes for knight to f6 the two
knights defense avoiding the evans
gambit with d3 bishop to c5 and now
castle so this is the joko pianissimo
very very standard stuff d6 c3 castles
and rook to e1 and now asking are you
maybe up for some knights the g knights
to g4 action uh but alireza didn't come
here to mess around he goes for a5
preventing b4
and now pawn to h3 stopping bishop to g4
we have bishop to a7 and now uh
interestingly uh alireza had this
position against yani palmichi and he
defeated him in norway chess where a4
was played uh but young continues with
knights the uh knights the a3 and young
continues a game that he actually lost
the grishok in the 2020 earthings
masters so uh it's uh very interesting
that he chooses this line uh but he
makes an improvement on that game that
we are going to discuss so here we have
h6 uh and now knight to b5 going for
elites is dark square bishop we have
bishop to b6 and now bishop to e3 uh
captures on e3 rook captures rook to e8
and here in the game against grishok
that nepal lost the uh um immediate the
d4 was played but here nipple plays
queen to b3 and it is not as of move 13
that we have a completely new game queen
to c2 and queen to b3 are the first
moves recommended by the engine so yeah
obviously nepo improved on his game
against the grishok in the air things
masters that we mentioned uh so okay
let's see how alireza deals with this
also he's putting pressure on f7 so we
need to do something about this either
rook to e7 or if you want to trade the
bishop to e6 this is what alerissa plays
bishop captures where rook captures and
only now pawn to d for striking in the
center and preparing the five to win
material so rogue back to e8 and pawn to
d5 winning more uh space in the center
knight to the e7 bioles and now pawn to
c4
grabbing more space in the center we
have knight to d7
uh now with ideas of maybe shifting the
rook back and uh executing f5 or maybe
the knight is coming to f8 to g6 and
then to f4
many many options here we have queen
back to c2 as the knight can also come
to c5 so queen to c2 and we do have
knight to c5 pawn to b3 as a b4 is
impossible due to the pawn here and now
rook to f8 preparing this pawn to f5
portion stops this he plays knights to
h4 and now pawn to c6 now that
everything
is uh nicely developed we have to
destroy ions a very strong center so the
captures on c6 b captures in c6 knight
back to c3 and now knight to e6 uh
eyeing all of these beautiful squares
here with this knight we have queen to
d2 and now knight to d4 now this is a
monster knight and of course it would be
very wise to get rid of it somehow so
rook to g3 by on uh putting pressure on
alireza's king with king to h7 getting
the king away from the g file and now
ponte f4 maybe a bit premature by on uh
maybe preparing with rook to f1 is
better but this is rapid chess so of
course uh many things could be better
but it's also good not to waste too much
time so here pawn to f4 uh and now uh
knight the g6 putting pressure on the
pawn and forcing a knight trade here
uh knight captures on g6 we have f
captures and g6 f captures on e5 d
captures an e5 and now also one of the
reasons why that rook to f1 move was
maybe better uh played then because if
you try it now then you run into a
knight f3 check and you blunder the
queen so
maybe also one of the reasons why it's
an improvement so rook to d3 yan
prevents this tricky idea and now queen
the h4 preparing to lift the rooks rook
to f4 is coming rook a2f8 is coming uh
and alireza is ready to attack jan's
king so here queen to e1 offering a
queen trade and alireza declines this he
goes back queen to e7 uh queen to h5
also uh very much playable kind of
keeping the queen where all the action
is maybe then preparing to push the g
pawn uh but alireza decides to bring the
queen all the way back and now rook 8 to
d1 jan doubles up on the d file uh next
he can shift the rook to d2 and then
maybe to f2 if needed so here rook to f4
alireza also prepares to double approx
with queen to e3 and now queen to g5
again bringing the queen where the queen
belongs and luckily you have the rook
here if the rook wasn't here then ideas
like rook to f1 check and picking up the
queen would become possible
but now everything is nicely protected
uh so king to h2
just getting the queen away from that
the g file
that the queen occupies rook 8 to f8
bringing the final attacker into the
attack and now rook 1 to d2 and
alireza's position is just spectacular
here and he plays the absolute strongest
move queen to h5 again now uh
not allowing the this pawn to move and
this is not a big problem as he is
preparing a very very nasty trick and uh
sorry not uh not quintage for queen to
h5 uh as he is preparing a very nasty
trick and there is only one way for
nipple to survive this attack uh and uh
of course you guys can already see what
alireza is planning uh but feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only move that saves the game for nepo
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on figuring this one
out as this is not an easy one to find
uh regardless of how much time you
invest and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course a
move with denied back but not knights
the d1 knight to e2 uh just to show you
what what would happen if you don't play
this let's say you try anything and
there really aren't as many moves you
can play here let's say try queen to g3
we just play g5 and the g for next and
the position just completely crumbles
let's say now you can't even play
knight's day 2 because the knight and
queen cover that
so let's say 91 you play g4 and i mean
there there's nothing for white to look
forward to here however after this
knight to e2 move ian found a
spectacular defensive resource
and this is the the one that he found if
you try g5 now uh now we just trade here
knight captures pawn captures queen
captures and now after g4 you have this
amazing rook the g3 and now if pawn
captures then uh alireza just gets
checkmated so g5 is out of the question
in this line however alireza does have
the main idea and that is knight to f3
with checks so how does jans knight the
e2 actually help him against this um uh
this check well this is what jan figured
uh we have upon captures on f3 rook
captures on f3 now attacking the queen
and now knight the g3 that's the idea
behind knight to the e2 and now alireza
has no choice other than to trade queens
because his queen has no squares if he
tries to save the queen then we just
play queen captures on f3 young gives up
the queen for all of this material and
he has two rooks and the knight for a
queen with the e4 pawn nicely defended
and jana would just win this uh very
easily uh so that's the idea so alireza
has to trade queens rook captures an e3
knight captures an h5 rook characters
and d3 rook captures and the g captures
on h5 and you get this position where
alireza is up upon but it's a doubled h
pawn of course the black is better but
is it enough to push for a win against
ian of course alireza will try with king
to g1 jan brings the king into the game
prevents the rook from infiltrating with
rook to f2 so rook to f4 going after the
pawn and jan just goes after alireza
spawn so rook d6 we have captures
captures and now rook to e2 going after
the a2 pawn so rook the c5 going after
the a5 and the e5 pawns uh and uh
alireza trades rook captures on a2 rook
captures on e5 in the now pawn to h upon
h4 the situation on the clock eight
minutes uh for jan and six minutes for
alireza for this end game where alireza
is still up upon uh and now in a rook
end game it usually doesn't matter if
you're up a pawn but if you have to
choose you know it's better to be up
upon than down upon so here rook to b5
uh and ponte a4 uh young
alireza uses this uh pawn to the mesa
piano spawn structure because jan for
the moment does have two connected past
pawns so b captures rook captures and
now rook to c5 defending his spawn and
now rook a3 going after the h3 pawn so
king g2 and king to g6 now alireza
starts bringing the king into the game
rook to c7 now if the king goes further
down the board then we pick up this pawn
we have rook to g3 with czech king the
h2 and the king to f5 now uh the rook
nicely defending the pawn pawn to c5 and
pawn to g5 we have rooked the c6 going
after this pawn here we have pawn to h5
rook to h6 now again going after the h5
pawn and now rook the c3 now trying to
trade off the double h1 for the
uh for the c5 pawn uh and although you
could push this pawn all the way to c6
jan decides to show his end game mastery
he plays rook captures on h5 uh we have
king to f4 and now king to g2
rook to c2 with check there's always
time to recapture on c5
and now king to g1 uh we have rook
captures on c5 if you go rook to if you
go king to g3 then rook captures and g5
comes with check so you are not in time
to check made the white king and after
captures on h3 this is a well-known uh
drawn position so after rook captures on
c5 we have kinked the g2 and now rook to
c2 with check king g1 we have rook to a2
of course alireza will still try to push
this king to h1 and rook to a5 now
we have king back to g2 and now rook to
b5 and now uh nipple has three minutes
on the clock alireza has only 15 seconds
on the clock he's been burning a lot of
time trying to find winning ideas uh
king to f2 uh we have rook to c5 and
king back to g2 ian just uh you know uh
strolling on unsafe squares here king to
e3 and now finally activating his rook
you have to check whether it's okay to
activate the rook if it's not you might
blunder the game
so jan did invest a few seconds uh so
king rook to h8 rook to c2 with czech
king to g1 and king to f3 hoping to get
the king to g3 without the g5 pawn being
under attack but of course alireza
doesn't allow this adjust rook to g8 and
now of course if you threaten checkmate
we pick up this pawn with check so rook
to c1 check king to h2 rook c2 king to
g1 and he was in this position at that
yanni pomnishi and alireza agree to a
draw as there is no more way to make
progress here the game might continue
let's say king g3 if you try to give up
the pawn we get a pretty similar
position that we discussed but now you
just keep the rook on the g file and
even if uh you allow a rook trade for
example rook to c3 going after rook to
g3 check it doesn't matter let's say
rook jade rook here delivers check
you're forced to trade uh this is again
a draw you have to have the king in
front of the pawn for this not to be a
draw and now you just play king to f1
and that of course is a joke that would
be a terrible blunder you just play king
to h1 g to check king g1 and king g3 and
it is a draw by
uh stalemate so that's why of course
both of them uh
both of them know this and that's why
they agreed to a draw so after king to
g1 uh a really really wild game uh
alireza was attacking nepo was also
playing in his
spectacularly weird style but here
also another example of how how
resilient and how tenacious uh yanni
pomnishi is even if you're attacking him
even if it seems like there's no way to
save the position
yan will just find a move like knight to
e2 and then you know he just strolls
through the game like nothing is
happening so really really remarkable uh
you know maybe something like um uh you
know
uh
vastly when choking into good old days
would would do not because of the night
moved
to the back but just because uh he just
plays uh yeah absolutely differently
than everyone else and still you know
gets amazing results
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it the first uh game that we are
showing from this rapid and blitz
tournament in croatia i would like to
thank david mcfarlane john austin
michael higgins dominique albers and
gordon mercer for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check uh uh uh
up on this wonderful tournament uh most
likely until it finishes uh so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out the video in the description about
magnus if you still haven't heard the
news uh see you soon